servus kirch und habe der ebene matthias
und heute spreche ich langsames
österreichisches deutsch mit euch
[Musik]
heute sind wir in zell am see zell am
see ist am salzburger land und salzburg
ist eines der neuen bundesländern von
österreich
[Musik]
die augen bedecken zwei drittel der
landesfläche für österreich und ganz
besonders stolz sind die berge die seen
und die gletscher meist ist
in österreich gibt es ganz verschiedene
delikte - salzburger an der grenze zu
österreich und das ist wie ihre aber in
einen anderen teil von österreich konnte
direkt ganz anders sein wie in
vorarlberg oder in die ruhe
[Musik]
der auslauf sieht man gleich drei sachen
für die österreich berühmt ist denn
wolfgang amadeus mozart die sie unser
ehemalige kaiserin und red bull
jedes red bull auf der ganzen welt wird
in österreich hergestellt
[Musik]
da im hintergrund sieht man typisches
österreichisches haus konsum ein
heiliger holzbalkone blumen die auch
klappten fenster leben und
österreichische fahne
[Musik]
also das hat man jetzt die typisch
österreichische landestracht sozusagen
an lederhosen für die burg ganz schämen
edelweiß auf dem hemd und addieren wir
für die magie hinter mir im haus ist die
österreichische fahne rot weiß rot und
das salzburger landesfahne in rot weiß
[Musik]
man begrüßt sich in österreich mit
servus pfiat eich was so viel bedeutet
wie ich grüße euch oder harvey dr
das bedeutet ich habe die ehre und beim
auf wiedersehen sagen sag mal vier teich
oder servus auch oder auch ganz häufig
[Musik]
die drei größten städte seien unser
bundeshauptstadt wien und der noch graz
und linz in österreich gibt ganz kurz
ist das wiener schnitzel oder karotten
oder ganz kritisierte sachen nieren
kaiserschmarrn oder marinello es war
unser episode aus zell am see in
österreich wenn ihr lust habt es nur
mehr übungen zu machen dann schauen sie
mal bei unsere apps ittling vorbei
setzen verstecken verstecken erkennen
erkennen und jetzt hast du noch mehr
[Musik]